hi this morning
uh i was thinking about this uh lockdown
the world over one way or another
most of the world is uh
being told that this virus we have to
being locked down some have to work i
know
but it stopped us training in our
in our loved art of aikido
and i was thinking about uh muscle
wastage memory
body memory you know there's a lot of
you
may be worrying that when it is time to
go back to
training on the mat you'll be forgotten
techniques or
you may be considering the fear of
will i have to start all over again
well i can tell you that if you've been
doing it for some time
your body will remember the techniques
and it will just come flooding back
the good news is it'll probably probably
not be much better
than before because
the body is a little bit like a slow
cooker
it's sometimes thinking or when you
don't realize it's thinking about
techniques
now this morning i got up and i felt
stiff my back was
aching a bit my shoulders felt tight
neck was tight
i had the advantage of being able to
do yoga
but my body knows what's tight
if i search around it or you may just
wake up
yourself feeling oh i feel stiff today
my advice for you is to go on the net
and
search out some yoga that you think will
suit you
not the poses that push you and you
don't think you'd like them but but
select the poses you think they would
help you
or there's a lot of aikido teachers out
there who are showing exercise
warm-up preparations that you can do
anywhere on the beach in your house
in the woods you don't have to just be
on the in the
on the tatami to do aikido
this brings me to another thought i was
watching a slow
motion movie in black and white of saito
sensei
he's in the woods in iwama with a
partner
and i noticed that i was watching
clearly how he was performing techniques
on his uk i wasn't
interested in looking at the uk i know
this
and you may know what i mean by this i
was looking at what
scentsy was doing as this was the part
that i would want to know
after all uk receives the technique from
nage they don't have to harmonize or
play a part
if the technique is correct they will go
where the direction of the technique
puts them
so if you're on lockdown
and you don't have a partner that you
can train with
you can train these techniques on your
own
some people call it shadow boxing
playing your role as nagoy
what i found over the years when i
didn't have a partner
but i've done a technique the night
before such as
let's say a shia nagi
i would play in my mind and i would
i would mimic the move making sure that
poguam was around looking at
me because it could be anywhere you know
may know what i'm talking about i could
be in the middle of the street and
perhaps turning a corner if nobody was
in the
street i would perhaps just try turning
my wrist over
the first part of the sheer naggy
anyhow if you look at a technique
in a book or on a film
you can take the time out to just
practice it on your own
you don't need uk and as you go
through these movements
trust me you will know if it's correct
or not
your senses will tell you are you
turning too much are you not turning
enough
how is the motion going is it smooth
don't get lost in the glory of enjoying
the technique
but get lost in the glory of doing it
and finding how to make it smoother
because i can tell you at my level
that's what you're experiencing when you
do have a partner
you're experiencing the smoothness as if
you're both
one and if you don't reach this level
eventually of two people becoming one
you and your attacker you're in your
blended partner
it's all the same it's another human
being
that you are blending with them they are
not
having to blend with you this is the
correct way around aikido should be
if uki blends with you then they're
doing
aikido you're not
and you become okay even though
the onlooker would think that you're the
ones doing the technique
i hope you found this of interest
and please try on a few techniques
and you may surprise yourself on how
difficult
it is to go from start to finish
and to find no faults
and this way you can keep training
through any lockdowns
and you can improve your aikido so when
the day comes
hopefully you will return to your
training
some will have given up perhaps many
they may have become bored with the
weight
but you do have your body and you do
have your mind
and you are with your these two
24 7 so i would like you to do something
with it
and not just worry about what you can't
do
think about what you can
your body needs to be exercised and your
mind needs to be expanded
and by doing your aikido in this way
and looking after your body with yoga or
some
warm-up preparations will mean
a healthier life than what you would
have by doing nothing thank you
please subscribe to my channel if you
enjoy these
and i'll talk to you soon bye for now